Phil you just saw watchdogs three
watchdogs Legion watchdogs Legion as
they've announced other rumors true the
rumors are true you can play any NPC in
the game it's kind of crazy actually
what you're doing is building an army of
dedsec hackers and you can have up to 20
of them and as you're wandering in the
world if you you know zap somebody with
your little profiler and see they have
perks they have information about what
they are like if you like those people
you can recruit them on your team it
takes some work but you can play as
anybody in the game what kind of work if
need to recruit them so the way it works
is everybody in the game has like an
opinion of dedsec right so if they don't
like dedsec the hacker group that you're
part of they they take a lot more
convincing basically you have to work
them up to being pro dedsec and what you
can do is when you use the profiler you
find out information about what their
deal is if they have say people who are
related to them who are in jail or a
loan shark after that I'm something like
that you can then help them out with
those problems raise their opinion of
dedsec so eventually side missions that
basically like all the NPC's are super
well built out so they have schedules
and jobs and stuff that they're doing
out in the world you can find where
they're gonna be based on their schedule
what you find out about them through the
database like intercept them at those
places so is there a database that's
just like every citizen in this game I
guess so every you know you remember the
profiler from the other watchdog games
right were you just like you know look
at somebody and yeah like just weird
things like oh this I had an NPC today
when I played he apparently like punched
his uncle in the chest to restart his
heart one time and like sin' you know
your tidbits like that
well those tidbits are a lot more
fleshed out and a lot of them kind of
like include you know what's going on in
these people's lives and yeah if you can
help them out with stuff in the world
wherever they are you can raise their
opinion of debts I can eventually
recruit them and then it requires you to
go on a mission that like you know
it's an origin mission basically to get
that character on your team then once
they agree to be part of that SEC you
can play as them you can switch to them
anytime you want to interesting is there
like it kind of begs the question is
there are there permadeath elements like
if your people die that's yeah so they
can be killed they can be captured they
can be wounded they can be like stuck in
the hospital for a while it doesn't
happen all the time obviously like you
kind of have to commit to getting a
character killed to get them killed it
sounded like but yeah they can they can
be knocked out and that's it oh you are
done now so then who's the protagonist
yeah I'm not really super clear on that
I'm really well here's the thing so the
protagonist is whatever character you
want to build whatever NPC you recruit
whatever they're like I played a couple
of Story cutscenes and whoever I was
playing at that moment that character
was the main character of the game and
they're all like different the
animations the story or the dialogue the
the accents the voice acting all of that
is specific to each of the characters I
mean I don't know what the top end is
they wouldn't tell me but there's got to
be you know templates in there but I
didn't you know see any crossover they
showed four videos of the same cutscene
running at the same time with four
different characters and they all look
different in different voice acting and
Wow yeah okay so yeah I don't know how
you get to that's you know who starts
dedsec in London yeah before you start
recruiting all these people but all
intents and purposes in the game it
seems like whoever you want to be
whoever you want the main character to
beat that's who the main characters in a
does take place in London so so that was
true as well
London's pretty populated so there's
yeah I imagine they make they make this
populate at least two what you'd expect
from an open-world game like there's
NPCs walking around and all these NPCs
have backstories you can interact with
it's kind of mind-blowing yeah it's nuts
they I feel like they must have built a
bunch of new tech that they haven't
really told us about yet but it's it was
really pretty impressive just how much
went into all these characters and yeah
and then you know they're very diverse
there's a lot of space in London I was
in
two different areas one was like kind of
room down one was a little more posh I
guess and and the characters were
different based on those areas you know
so like the the the poorer folks had
like a better opinion of debt sack they
were maybe a little bit easier to
recruit their perks might have been a
little different you know I all the
characters have different traits you
know some are better brawling somewhere
better hacking there are also three
character classes for these NPCs that
you can assign them and then they get
special perks from that and they have
different abilities based on which class
you pick so there's a lot going on there
yeah yeah it is in fact another room
that's been around that Clinton Hawking
who directed Splinter Cell special chaos
theory Far Cry 2 especially the Far Cry
2 he's known for doing some pushing a
lot of boundaries and he hasn't made a
game since but the rumor is is that he's
been working on watchdogs 3 and that is
in fact true yes created jerking yeah he
gave us a quick presentation I can get
to talk to him but he ran through just
all that stuff that I just told you and
more it was it's it seems pretty intense
I was I was pretty impressed you know I
liked watchdogs to quite a bit and this
seems like it's advancing all those good
ideas from that game in a number of ways
yeah watchdogs to kind of felt like a it
was like a lower budget tech focused GTA
game right which was fun but it didn't
really have much of an identity I felt
and it seems like they're they've really
found something interesting to do with 3
yeah it's uh there's a lot going on
there I guess there are five different
stories that they're telling throughout
the game I'm again not really super
clear on how all that works out but yeah
this it's going real hard in a in a very
specific direction so during this
presentation they also gave you a
release date as well right right March
sixth 2020 okay so that's early next
year
yeah relatively soon cool so anyway for
more III coverage make sure to stay
tuned the game spot thank you thanks
[Music]